[प्रशंसा]
[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों एक बार
बता दीजिए की आप सबको मेरी आवाज ए रही है
नहीं ए रही
थैंक यू
टॉम ज्यादा वेट नहीं करेंगे हम अपना टॉपिक
कंटिन्यू करेंगे बट देखते हैं की कुछ 5
मिनट के बाद कितने लोग आते हैं कितने लोग
जॉइन करते हैं एटलिस्ट कल वाली ट्रेन तो
चाहिए चाहिए
क्योंकि जब कल प्रॉमिस आप लोगों के
ट्वेंटी 27 लाइव पर थे उसे टाइम पर आप लोग
तो आप लोग
तो आप सभी का स्वागत युटुब चैनल पर तो आप
लोगों से रिक्वेस्ट है जितने भी लोग हैं
प्लीज बीच में छोड़कर ना जाएगा काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक चल रहा है और आने वाला
टाइम में जितने भी क्लासेस रहेंगे साड़ी
ही बहुत ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाली है
काफी कुछ आपको सीखने को मिलने वाला है तो
अगर आप लोगों को मैं सेशन अच्छे लगता हैं
आप लोग को लगता है की आप प्रोविजनिंग सम
अवेलेबल इनफॉरमेशन
जब के लिए काफी हेल्प करने वाली है तो
आईडी बनाकर वहां जाइए और हमारे पेज पर
जाकर आपको क्या करना है कमेंट करना है
उससे हमें आपकी ज्यादा प्रेजेंस के बड़े
में मालूम बहुत ही आप कितने एक्टिविटी कम
कर रहे हैं हमारी प्रेजेंट क्लास के साथ
कंटिन्यू चल रहा है इस क्लासेस में चल रहा
है तो हम मैक्सिमम प्रैक्टिस के लिए करने
वाले हैं लैब के थ्रू तो काफी कुछ सीखने
को मिलेगा ताकि आप लोगों हैंडसम हो जाए की
कैसे की कोई भी इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग की जाति
है
उसके बाद फरदर टॉपिक पर चले जाएंगे तो मैं
बता चुका हूं पहले ही पॉइंट हम सीखने वाले
हैं यह मैं बता चुका हूं की इमेज रिवर्स
सर्च कैसे करते हैं ये सबको आपको पता है
और कुछ जो इंपॉर्टेंट है एग्जिट पाल मेटा
डाटा इमेज की ये भी मैं बता चुका हूं आप
लोगों को कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट प्वाइंट्स थे
ओसियन से रिलेटेड मैं आपको बता चुका हूं
जिसने जिसको नहीं पता जो आज फर्स्ट दे
क्लास जॉइन किया है किसी ने भी तो वह
प्लीज जाइए और लास्ट क्लास थी उसको पक्का
देखना इस के बेस पर हमारी क्लासेस चल रही
है तो कुछ है कैसे आप किसी भी इमेज को जिओ
लॉकेट कर सकते हैं और एक एग्जांपल था सेंड
का जो हम कर चुके हैं इस इमेज को देखकर
तो मोस्टली मुझे लगता है की लोगों ने कर
लिया होगा जिन्होंने नहीं किया की जल्दी
फटाफट कीजिए इसको और आई डोंट नो भाई क्यों
लोग ग्रुप में पूछते हैं भैया मैंने जब एक
वेबसाइट को बता दिया की इस वेबसाइट पर
जाइए सोफिया संतोष की है उसके बाद आप वहां
से उसकी इनफॉरमेशन मिल शक्ति है वहां से
जाके टास्क नंबर 7 शायद जो भी है उसको
क्या करना है आपको देखना है तो क्यों फिर
भी आपको स्पेशल प्रोवाइड करने की क्या
रिक्वायरमेंट जब मैं आपको चैनल पर बता
चुका हूं वहां जान के बाद आपको एक गूगल से
अच्छी तो करना है अगर आप एक वेबसाइट को
सर्च नहीं कर सकते जो की लाइव है जी पर
आपका टास्क है तो आप कैसे हैं की मैं
सरसों इमेज के बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन निकलोगे
ये मुझे समझ में नहीं आता तो आज का तू है
एग्जांपल तू है जो हम क्या करने वाले हैं
आज की क्लास में सीखने वाले हैं कुछ अगर
कुछ भी टूल से लेकर अगर कुछ हम एडिशन
इनफॉरमेशन देने में तो हम क्लास के बीच
में ही मैं आपको प्रोवाइड करूंगा स्पेशल
से कोई इसके लिए कोई स्लाइड या स्पेशल से
कोई इसके लिए लेक्चरर्स नहीं होगा क्योंकि
टोटली प्रेटिकल्स हम करने वाले हैं काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग प्रैक्टिकल करने वाले हैं
तो
तो हम जो देखने वाले हैं आज का टास्क क्या
है की डी इमेज बिलो इस ए स्क्रीनशॉट टेकन
फ्रॉम एसियाड क्लासीफाइड डॉक्यूमेंट आईटी
डिकपिक्स एक कैप्शन देव को रिपोर्ट ऑफ एन
अनडिस्क्लोज फोटो टेकन बाय
टेक्स्ट मेंशन स्कोप बीइंग असेंबल आते
फैक्ट्री योर टास्क इस तू फाइंड ए फोटो
डेट मैच डी डिस्क्रिप्शन ऑन डी कैप्शन
रिपोर्ट आपको एक पहले टास्क आपका ये है की
एक वो फोटो फाइंड आउट करना है की जो इस
डिस्क्रिप्शन को फूली मैच करता है
एग्जैक्ट मैच करता है डी एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन
ऑफ वेयर डी तेल इसको वॉच कंप्लीटेड और
आपको वो एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन फाइंड आउट करनी
है उसे फोटो के बेस पर की ये जब एक बार जो
कम चल रहा था वो कंप्लीट होने के बाद कहां
पर है प्रेजेंट लोकेशन के साथ तो वो
कोऑर्डिनेट्स भी आपको प्रोवाइड करने हैं
काफी इसमें ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन नहीं है
हमारे पास करने के लिए वो फोटो हम आपके
सामने लेकर आया हूं ये है वो फोटो जिसके
बेसिस पे हम अपने एनालिसिस करेंगे जिसके
बेसिस पर हमने ट्रांसफर फॉर्म करने वाले
हैं जो यह
तो एक चीज यहां पर डिस्क्लेमर बोल सकते
हैं की जितने भी यहां पर आपको प्रैक्टिस
करवाई जा रही है साड़ी एजुकेशन परपज के
लिए है और जितने भी इनफॉरमेशन हम यहां पर
आपने एक्सरसाइज में उसे कर रहे हैं वो
हमने एक सो टायर सेंटॉस नाम की वेबसाइट से
लिया है जो ओसियन की प्रैक्टिस के लिए
उन्होंने काफी अच्छी एक्सरसाइज प्रोवाइड
भी हुई है तो वेरी थैंकफूल तू यू बट
ये सब एजुकेशन परपज के लिए इनका किसी भी
तरह से आप गलत तरीका बताने के लिए फायदा
उठाने के लिए नहीं है तो ये फोटो है तो
इसके बड़े में हम प्रैक्टिकल स्टार्ट करते
हैं की जल्दी से ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट हम
नहीं करेंगे नहीं तो चलो लेट स्टार्ट
प्रैक्टिकल
मुझे अपने
चाय की चिप लिया था जरूरी है
ओके चलो हम चलते हैं अपने सोफिया ओके है
ओके ओके ओके ओके
हम डाउनलोड करते हैं इसके बेसिक पे पूरा
एनालिसिस करेंगे अब ये रहा ये वही इमेज है
अब इमेज को देखिए आपको इमेज को देख के
क्या ग रहा है इमेज को देख के आपको क्या ग
रहा है देखो
मैं अपना मतलब की आप पहले बात तो क्या है
की जो इमेज है जो भी इसमें रिपोर्ट लिखी
गई है वह पुरी इंग्लिश में ही है आपको
किसने दिखाई दे रही है इंग्लिश में ही
दिखाई दे रही है तो देखिए तो यहां पर कुछ
चीज हैं जो आप पढ़ के समझ में ए जाएगी
जैसे यहां पर आपको कैप्शन रिपोर्ट आप
पढ़ोगे आपको पता चल रहा है की ये कोई भी
फोटो है जो रिपोर्ट कहां पर बनाएगी इसकी
जर्मनी कंट्री जर्मनी स्पेशलिंग बर्लिन
मतलब की जो रिपोर्ट है ये कहां की है
बर्लिन की है जर्मनी में बर्लिन की तो
यहां पे एक तो ये चीज पता चल गया आपको
इससे दूसरा आपको कोऑर्डिनेट्स भी आपको पता
चल जाए 53 31 नोटिफिकेशन
भी आपको इस इमेज की हेल्प से आपको देखने
को मिल रहे हैं तो यहां पर कॉन्टिनेंट की
भी इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिल रही है
अगर सबको आपके स्क्रीन पर दिखाई देगा तो
उसके बाद आपको ये डिस्क्रिप्शन है
डिस्क्रिप्शन पढ़ने हैं की इससे हमें क्या
समझ में आता है
असकानिया फैक्ट्री फ्रॉम डी यूनिवर्सिटी
ऑफ बोन पर डी यूनिवर्सिटी ऑफ बोर्ड
साइज ऑफ डी माउंट पार्लर टेलिस्कोप
कैमरा इस 20 फिट वेट 310
जनवरी 18 1953
मतलब इसमें कुछ डिस्क्रिप्शन आपको मेंशन
किया मतलब क्या है की जो रिपोर्ट से अगर
हम एनालिसिस करते हैं क्योंकि देखो अभी
हमारे पास सबसे बड़ा चैलेंज ये है की
हमारे पास फोटो नहीं है सबसे बड़ा चैलेंज
ये है की हमारे पास फोटो नहीं है हमें
सबसे पहले इसको एनालिसिस करना की इसके बेस
पे हम क्या-क्या इनफॉरमेशन हम एक नोट्स
में रख सकते हैं पहले बात तो ये ताकि
रिपोर्ट में भर लेने की है जर्मनी में कुछ
कोऑर्डिनेट्स की यहां पर इनफॉरमेशन है
हमारे पास क्या है यहां पर एक टेलिस्कोप
है मतलब टैली कॉर्प टेलिस्कोप की
इनफॉरमेशन है कहां पर ये बनाया गया है
फैक्ट्री
की फैक्ट्री बनाया गया है किसके लिए
यूनिवर्सिटी ऑफ बोन बोन की यूनिवर्सिटी के
लिए उसके बाद क्या है की मतलब अब यहां पर
एक और इनफॉरमेशन आप देखने में मिल रही
होगी की बीइंग असेंबल आते फैक्ट्री मतलब
इसको फैक्ट्री में असेंबल किया गया है
उसके बाद इसमें क्या होता जो साइज होगा
इसका वो 20 टाइम्स बिगर दें डी अमाउंट पलस
तेल इसको मतलब कोई माउंट
सैटेलाइट
तो ऑटोमेटेकली इसका मतलब कोई ये कोई छोटा
सा तेल इसको ये कोई बड़ा तेल इसको यहां पे
बात हो रही है दूसरा क्या है की जो स्टार
का साइज देख सकते हैं
मतलब की
इसमें कुछ ज्यादा ही बड़ा साइज हम देख
सकते हैं स्टार का और यह रिपोर्ट कब की है
जनवरी 18 1953 यह साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन यहां पे
आपको देखने को मिल रही है तो इसके बेस पे
हम एनालिसिस करते हैं तो देखो किसी भी
रिपोर्ट के लेक किसी भी इमेज को लेकर
हमारे पास कुछ सवाल होते हैं
ये चार-पांच होते थे किसने कब कहा ठीक है
ये साड़ी चीज आपको देखने को मिलेगी अब
हमारे पास कुछ सवालों का जवाब यहां पर की
हमारे पास बट वे हैव और व्हेन 300 वालों
का जवाब यहां पर हमारे पास 300 वाला जो है
बट व्हाट में क्या है एक टेलिस्कोप
में क्या है हमारे पास कहां पर है
क्वेश्चन नंबर दो भी हमारे पास है
क्वेश्चन नंबर थ्री बहन कब मतलब जनवरी
1953 तो तीन सवालों का जवाब तो हमारे पास
है व्हाट वेयर
कहां मतलब और तो हो गया मतलब इसके बेस पर
हमें क्या करना है आपको इनफॉरमेशन को क्या
करना है अब निकालना है तो जो हम एनालिसिस
करेंगे इन तीनों सवालों के बेसिस पे
करेंगे बट व्हेन और वेयर तो गूगल सर्च भी
हम क्या करते हैं इन्हीं तीनों के सवाल पे
बेसिस पे स्टार्ट करेंगे क्योंकि हमें
क्या करना है अब हमें यहां पर अपनी
इनफॉरमेशन को फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करनी है तो चलते हैं हम गूगल पे तो बी अगर
बीच-बीच में अगर मैं थोड़ा सा स्टॉप होता
हूं दो सेकंड एक सेकंड के लिए तो आई एम
टेकिंग मी टी तो अगर आप लोग भी साथ के साथ
कम कर दो यू कैन टेक अलसो टेक आईटी
चलो हम गूगल करते हैं फिर गूगल पे चलते
हैं तो हमारे पास क्या है हमारे पास है
तो हमारे पास क्या है टेलिस्कोप
हमारे पास क्या है हमारे पास ये मैंने
पहले इस पर ऑलरेडी कम कर चुका हूं इस पे
तो डोंट गूगल में इंटर कर देते हैं सिंपली
यहां से हमें क्या मिलता है देखो हमारे
पास क्या आइडिया सबसे पहले चलते हैं पहले
इसको के बड़े में बाकी कुछ बहुत कुछ है
बाकी हम क्या करते हैं सबसे पहले वाले
रिपोर्ट पे चलते हैं की इमेज
image.com पे इस पे चलते हैं ये देखो यहां
पर कुछ क्या लिखा हुआ है और
ओके हमारे पास इनफॉरमेशन
मिली है
जो हम अब एनालिसिस करने की कोशिश करते हैं
तो इस इनफॉरमेशन पुरी पढ़ने हैं हम इसमें
क्या इनफॉरमेशन है 1 मिनट में क्या करता
हूं जो भी मेरी इमेज हमारी इमेज ए अब मैं
इसको क्या करता हूं एक बार
न्यू ब्राउज़र को ओपन कर सकता हूं इसको
मैं डुप्लीकेट नहीं बना सकते इसको मैं
क्या कर सकता हूं एक मैं से कर लेट हूं
इसको मैं और ओपन करता हूं उसके बाद इसको
मैं इमेज
जेनेटिक टाइल्स को बिल्ड इन बर्लिन
फैक्ट्री पर डी फर्स्ट टाइम साइंस थे वर्स
जनवरी 1953
पर डी फर्स्ट टाइम साइंस थे वार आई
टेलिस्कोप हस बिन बट इन डी बर्लिन
फैक्ट्री ऑफ स्कैनिया मतलब एक इनफॉरमेशन
है मतलब इस में इसको बनाया गया है यहां पर
क्या लिखा हुआ है
फैक्ट्री ओके पर डी यूनिवर्सिटी
ऑफ बोर्ड
इसके साथ मैच कर रही है
तू स्टडी और टेक पिक्चर ऑफ स्टार्ट ओके तो
विद दिस टेलिस्कोप तारा ऑफ डी 23 कैन बी
सीन ओके तो विद दिस टेनिस को स्टार्ट ऑफ
डी कंट्री
दूसरी हमारी डिस्क्रिप्शन इसके साथ मैच
को ओके इसका मतलब जो एक और डिस्क्रिप्शन
क्या कंफर्म कर दिया एक और डिस्कशन मैच कर
गया तो साइज ऑफ डी कैमरा 20 फिट साइज है
वेट मतलब क्या है की जी टाइप्स के
डिस्क्रिप्शन इस रिपोर्ट से हमें देखने को
मिल रहा है इस इमेज
के बेस पे अगर हम एनालिसिस करते हैं उसे
एनालिसिस के बेस पर हमें जो पिक्चर्स हमें
अगर एक तरफ आइडिया पिक्चर्स का मिला हमारे
पास ये वो पिक्चर्स है जो हमें देखने को
मिल रही है हमारे स्क्रीन के साथ
ठीक है तो इस टाइप की आपको यह देखने को
मिल रही है पिक्चर
वह पिक्चर हो शक्ति है जिसके हम बात कर
रहे हैं देखो साइज भी काफी बड़ा है और ऊपर
कुछ कैमरा कैमरा टाइप का लगा हुआ है तो
काफी कुछ है मतलब अभी भी हम सर नहीं है की
क्या ये पिक्चर्स हो भी शक्ति है यानी
देखो हमारे पास जैसे एक रिपोर्ट थी और
रिपोर्ट के बेस पर जो हमारे सेंस बन रही
थी जो हम वेरीफाई कर का रहे थे जो चीज हम
एक डॉक्यूमेंट के डिस्क्रिप्शन के बेस पर
हम जो चीज हम निकाल सकते हैं हमारे सामने
इधर है क्योंकि इसमें जो डिस्क्रिप्शन है
ये वो डिस्क्रिप्शन है बिल्कुल से है बट
वे आर नोट रेडी दम सो की हम शोर नहीं है
की हम क्या करना है तो इसको वेरीफाई करने
के लिए इस इनफॉरमेशन को हम क्या करेंगे
थोड़ा और रिसर्च करेंगे की क्या ये पिक्चर
एग्जिट है या नहीं है देखो एक चीज ध्यान
में रखा
की यहां पर एक चीज आप नोटिस की होगी की जो
यहां पर लिखा है इसने की इसको क्या है
बनाया गया है असेंबल किया गया इस फैक्ट्री
के अंदर बनाया गया यूनिवर्सिटी मतलब क्या
है की इसको किसी सर्च किसी पर पक्ष से
इमेज को बनाया गया है बेसिकली
डिस्क्रिप्शन के आधार पर तो हो सकता है की
अब जब इसको यूनिवर्सिटी बोन के लिए बनाया
गया है तो उसके अंदर इसको प्लेस भी किया
होगा उसे परपज के लिए तो अगर वहां पर
प्लेस किया होगा कहानी ना कहानी किसी ने
किसी ने तो इसका फोटो लिया ही होगा ऐसा तो
हो सकता है की किसी ने किसी र से क्योंकि
इतनी पॉपुलर चीज है इतनी फेमस चीज है तो
किसी ने किसी ने तो इसका क्या किया होगा
फोटो तो लिया ही होगा इमेज लिया पिक्चर
लिया होगा
चलो प्रिया पता करने की कोशिश करते हैं तो
अब हम क्या किया
फूल स्क्रीन पे ए जाते हैं तो हम थोड़ा सा
अब क्या करते हैं गोल सर्च करते हैं अभी
हम गूगल सर्च करते हैं ऑलरेडी मैं कर चुका
हूं वैसे एक बार करता हूं पहले इसको अब
क्या मेरे पास ये रहा मैं सेकंड में
ऑलरेडी कर चुका था टाइगर स्कोप
यूनिवर्सिटी 1953 अब मैं इसको ऐसे क्या
करना छह रहा हूं मैं ऐसे ही करने की कोशिश
करता हूं और हिट इंटर करता हूं तो ये अब
इससे मुझे क्या इनफॉरमेशन मिलती है अब
मेरे पास फिर एक वैरायटी का सबसे ऊपर मैं
आर्टिकल आया चाहे तो मैं कितने भी आते का
ओपन कर सकता हूं कोई सुन्नी तो हम पहले
सबसे फर्स्ट वाला आर्टिकल ओपन करने की
कोशिश कर सकते हैं ये रहा तो इस आर्टिकल
हम क्या करते हैं ओपन करते हैं इस आर्टिकल
में क्या है तो इस आर्टिकल में क्या है ये
क्या है देखते हैं इसमें कैटिगरी
उसमें कुछ है इसमें ओल्ड मोनो ये कुछ लोग
इसमें देखो कुछ लोकेशन मेंशन है
ओके बस अभी हमें इसमें कुछ पता नहीं है
ओके ये बिल्डिंग हो सकता है तो हम मैच
करने की कोशिश करते हैं वो डिस्क्रिप्शन
जिसकी हम बात करें की इसके साथ क्योंकि जो
हमने एक मिनट हमने ओके हमने प्रॉब्लम
क्रिएट की तो हम उसे फोटो को हमने अभी तक
क्या किया से नहीं किया तो हम एक कम करते
हैं उसको पहले
कॉलेज फोटो
है इस फोटो को हम क्या करते हैं
इसके आधार पर हम क्या करते हैं अब
एनालिसिस करने की कोशिश करते हैं क्या ये
वही फोटो है तो हम करते हैं
[संगीत]
तो अब हम क्या करते अपनी फोटो
है नहीं है तो हम इसको पहले कट कर देते
अभी इससे पता करने की कोशिश करते हैं मैच
करने की
कोई हमें ऐसी कोई इमेज मिलती है जो इसको
क्या कर सके कंफर्म कर सकें ये अब ये तो
है नहीं क्योंकि काफी छोटा सा साइज है
काफी कुछ इसमें है नहीं देखो इसका
डिस्क्रिप्शन
नो
पॉसिबल नोट काफी छोटा है क्योंकि इमेज जो
कंफर्म नहीं कर उसके बाद गोडाउन गोडाउन
गोडाउन ओके ओके
दिस अलसो नोट देवर ओके ओके ये भी नहीं है
तो अब ये बात ये भी नहीं है ये भी नहीं है
और ये ओके ओके
यह हो सकता है बट चांसेस बट एग्जिट उसे
इमेज को मैच करने कोशिश करें
चलो फिर हम क्या करते हैं अब हमें सेकंड
क्वेश्चन था जो हमारा सेकंड था वो पता
करने की कोशिश करते हैं की एग्जैक्ट
लोकेशन क्या होगी इस टेलिस्कोप की कहां पर
तो अब हमें कम करते हैं की ये आर्टिकल है
तो यहां पर हमें कुछ इनफॉरमेशन देखने को
मिल रही है क्या इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिलती
है की 34 50 सेंटीमेंट
टेलिस्कोप मतलब आपके पास का नाम है उसके
बाद क्या है ये है अस्कानिया बर्लिन 1954
ओके तो मतलब 1 साल तो लगेगा उसको और उसके
बाद इसमें क्या है और लिस्ट टावर 1953 54
ओके और फोटो तो हमारे पास क्या है
टेलिस्कोप का नाम हमारे पास चलो हमारे पास
का नाम है इसको हम गूगल कर लेते हैं पहले
बात तो ये क्या चीज है ओके कॉपी करते हैं
चलो हम अपना गूगल असिस्टेंट
इसको सर्च करेंगे बट हमारे पास अभी थोड़ा
सा ऑपरेटर का उसे करने की कोशिश करेंगे
1954 में 1953 तो हम क्या करते हैं एक तो
एक कम करने की कोशिश करते हैं की ओके इसको
हम डबल को के अंदर मैसेज करके हमें एडवांस
गूगल सर्च ओपन उसे करने वाले हैं ऊपर से
क्या है ओके हम
बदले उसके बाद
1953 1953 8 इंटर करते हैं कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
हमें मिलती है क्या ये हैंडबैग
यूनिवर्सिटी
अगर हम इमेज
वही चीज देखो अब इमेज में हम जाते हैं तो
इमेज देखते हैं तो यहां पर वो साड़ी चीज
देख लो ये वाली जो फोटो हमारे पास ऑलरेडी
है उसके बाद और कोई ऐसी इमेज जो हम देख का
रहे हैं या पर एग्जांपल जैसे की मैं इसको
क्या ओपन करता हूं और ये इनफॉरमेशन मेरे
पास है उसके अलावा और कोई ये भी वही से है
इसके अलावा और कुछ और कुछ मुझे लगता है
क्या होगी क्या हो शक्ति है वह इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिल रही है देखो यहां पर मतलब
इसको बनाया जा रहा होगा इसका कंस्ट्रक्शन
हो रहा होगा तो यहां पर क्या है कुछ
इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिल का रही है
अभी मैं इसको विजिट करता हूं इस वेबसाइट
को तो देखो हमारे पास एक क्लियर इमेज है
क्लियर इमेज अगर मैं इसको जो आपको जूम
करके दिखाऊं देखो ये रहा हमारे पास एक
इमेज है से वही डिस्क्रिप्शन मैच कर रहा
है तो ये फूल इमेज मतलब वर्कर्स इस पे कम
कर रहे होंगे या जिन्होंने इनको कर सकते
हो मुझे और एक वो चीज देखोगे यहां पर अगर
मैं जूम करता हूं तो एक कम करते हैं इसको
हम न्यू पेज में टाइम ओपन करते हैं और ये
देखो हमारे पास देखो हमारे पास कुछ और
इनफॉरमेशन है मतलब की ये देखो कुछ इसका
कुछ क्या है एक प्रेजेंटेशन टाइप का ग्राफ
टाइप का भी है तो इस ओके कोई मतलब नहीं
अभी वैसे इनफॉरमेशन ये भी काफी अच्छा
स्टेप्स है तो अब देखो ये इनफॉरमेशन हमारे
पास मिल गई तो गूगल इमेज हम सर्च कर पे नो
ओके
तो ये हो गया उसके बाद हम चलते हैं
वेबसाइट
करना है की ये एग्जैक्ट में कहां पर हो गई
है अब एग्जैक्ट पे कहां पर होगी
कपड़ों की तो यह पता करने के लिए हमारे
पास इसमें एक लोकेशन मेंशन की हुई है
टावर 1993 ओके टावर
1994 ओके तो हम क्या करते हैं इसके हमने
कुछ इसके ऊपर अगर नोटिस किया हो जो
वेबसाइट ऊपर से नीचे फोल्ड कर रहे थे तो
हमने कुछ देखा था की एक तो इसके
लट्टीट्यूड लोंगिट्यूड हम यहां पर कहानी
मेंशन थे इलेक्ट्रोलाइज पे कहानी मेंशन थे
जब सबसे फ्रंट में हमने देखा था तो हम देख
सकते हैं इसके बेसिक पे ये रहा इसने क्या
दिखाए है की ओके ऑन एजेंडा पब्लिकली ओनर
देखो और लिस्ट का हमारे पास इलेक्ट्रॉन
होंगे अवेलेबल है ये रहा लट्टीट्यूड और
लोंगिट्यूड तो हमारे पास ये है ओके तो
हमें एक कम करते हैं
तो
इनको और
इसको आप गूगल मैप में ओपन करेंगे इसको
पेस्ट करके रख लेते हैं
तो एक बार मैं ओके उसके बाद
इंटर करते हैं क्या इसके बेसिक
होता है
नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो
नो
इंटरनेट अच्छा चल रहा है बट वही टेकिंग सो
मैच टाइम
कर लेते हैं
दिस एनीथिंग इस अवेलेबल ऑन डी मैप
शो
[संगीत]
लिटिट्यूड लोकेशन
पर ओके यह होता है 29
वर्ल्ड कप
टेस्ट करते हैं
ओके ओके यह
फाइंड समथिंग
फोटोस मिलेंगे तो मिल जाएंगे हम देखने को
देख सकते हैं यहां पर अवेलेबल है इसमें
देखने को ये रहा इसी लोकेशंस के सारे
फोटोस हैं
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
क्या है टावर फोर है यह टावर वन देखो आप
एक बार टावर वन की इमेज यह है मतलब क्या
है इसके पास क्या आपको क्या दिखा है इसका
एनालिसिस करोगे तो डाउनलोड ऐसे एक इसके
साइड में बिल्कुल बिल्डिंग है पेड़ है एक
छोटा सा वाक्य बना हुआ है यह मतलब इस टाइप
को इस साइड में पेड़ है तो हम क्या करते
हैं हमारे पास टावर वन कौन सा हो सकते हैं
इनमें से
कौन से डेट की अब टावर होना भी उसे टाइप
से अगर हम देखें तो हमें ये होना चाहिए
क्योंकि देखो तीन बेंच चीज है एक छोटा सा
पांचवें बना हुआ है और ऐसे ही कम वाली
वहां पर आपको दिखाई दे रहा है तो हम अभी
तक शोर नहीं की टावर नहीं होगा ऊपर से
क्या की अब देखो इस टाइप से यहां पर तो
हनी है वो चीज बट हम एक कम पोस्ट करते हैं
की आप हमें कुछ मिलता ए गया ओके हमारे पास
यहां पर एक है
ओके हम क्लिक करते हैं की यहां से हम क्या
देख पाते हैं तो यहां पर हम क्या देख पाते
देखो यहां से देखने कुछ करते हैं तो और तो
हमें कम करते हैं देखो
तो अगर हम इसको जूम करके देखें
हां इस टाइप से आपको दिखाई दे रहा है अगर
उसे लोग इस चीज को मैं देखा हूं ओके
बात करें हम ओपन करता हूं न्यू तब मैं
इसको भी मैं ओपन करता हूं ये रहा और इसको
अगर हम कोशिश करते हैं अभी देखो
अब इसको हम जूम करके देखें तो इसको देखो
कुछ यहां पर आपको मार्किंग दिखाई दे रहे
हो किधर है और इधर ही हम ऐसे ही देखो इधर
भी नाइट में ऐसे ही देख का रहे हैं इधर भी
ओके मतलब ये चीज हम देख का रहे है टावर
इसके तो अब जी टाइम की फोटो आप यहां पर
नहीं उसके बाद क्या ये ऐसे ही है ओके तो
ये चीज आप देखने को भी ये बिल्डिंग हैं
आपको ओके ये बिल्डिंग है आपकी ऐसे ही एक
छोटा सा पेड़ इधर भी दिखाई दे रहा है आपको
बिल्कुल छोटा सा पेड़ इधर सामने उसके मैं
आपको देखने को मिल रहा होगा अब यहां पर
नहीं ए रहा है क्योंकि सिंगल पे फोटो को
लिया गया है ये डिपेंड्स अब यहां पर क्या
ये इस एंगल से फोटो लिया गया है वो और
क्या है इसे गैस कर सकते हैं थोड़ा सा
देखो हां तो अगर ये रहा ये देख मतलब की हम
थोड़ा सा आइडिया लगाना पड़ेगा अभी उसके
बाद देखते हैं ओके ये वो बिल्डिंग है ये
वो बड़ा सा पेड़ है देखो अगर हम देखेंगे
ये वाला पेड़ है काफी अच्छा नजर यहां पर
देखो उसके बाद देखो यहां पर देखो तो अब ये
वो वाली पेड़ की छांव वाली होगी ये देखो
आपको दिखाई दे रही होगी तो जो हम इधर देख
का रहे हैं एक मिनट हां ओपन किया था हमने
ये वाले पेड़ के सामने
कुछ करते हैं ओके ये सामने एक ये ऊपर से
क्या एक ये पट्टी जा रही है मतलब कोई
रास्ता बना हुआ है नेक्स्ट उसके बाद आपको
दिक्कत है बहुत सारे फ्रेंड्स हैं आपको एक
ये दो दिखाई दे रही होगी ये रही मतलब
बिल्कुल जस्ट इस बिल्डिंग के यहां पास
पेपर ये एक ये दो दिखाई दे रही है मतलब
हां एक ये दो दिखाई दे रहे हो उसके बाद और
कुछ हम देख का रहे हैं उसके बाद क्योंकि
उससे लिया गया है और ओके ओके
तो बेसिकली क्योंकि देखो अब इसके बाद बैठ
जाते हैं तो हम एक चीज के मिक्सर हो
जाएंगे तो यह यहां से लिया गया है तो हम
क्या देख पे हम जो देख पे हैं इसके लिए जो
इस एंगल से भी लिया गया मतलब क्या है की
जो हम डम दे पाएं बेसिकली एक तो ये चीज
देख पे की ये वो ये वो टावर है टावर वन है
यहां से हम मेक सर हो गए दूसरा क्या है की
ये वाली चीज हम देख पे इधर ये वाला वो
पेड़ बड़े वाला पेड़ है ये वो रास्ता है
जो हमने देखा है उसके बाद हमने देखा तो
कुछ लोग क्योंकि काफी दूर से इमेज लिया है
तो मतलब इसी में इस बिल्डिंग का तो वही
इमेज आया नहीं होगा हो सकता की इन्हीं में
से किसी का ये रहा ये या ये इनमें से किसी
का वो एक और डम का है क्या इमेज आई होगी
क्योंकि इतना साइकिल चला है वो इमेज दिखाई
देती है मतलब ये भी हो शक्ति है वो
बिल्डिंग या ये हो शक्ति है बिल्डिंग तो
हमें थोड़ा सा आइडिया मिल गया था आइडिया
मिल गया मतलब ये आपका टावर वन हो सकता है
वो तो यहां पर अगर मैं ये देख रहा हूं बट
अभी तक क्या हम सर हैं की वो इसी टावर में
देखा कैसे हम सर करेंगे ये हमें थोड़ी
चाहिए होगी की क्या टावर वन में ही रखा
गया है क्या वो थोड़ा सा क्लेरिटी चाहिए
हमें तो इसकी क्लेरिटी कौन दे सकता हूं
मैं इसकी क्लेरिटी हमें युटुब दे सकता है
तो हम देख सकते हैं चलो की उसकी क्लेरिटी
के लिए हम युटुब पर जाते हैं युटुब पे
सर्च मारेंगे अगर हम युटुब पे कम करते हैं
सर्च करते हैं युटुब पर कौन सा था
तो ऑब्जर्वर ऑब्जर्वेटरी
हा ओ लिस्ट
उसमें
देखो एनालिसिस में हमेशा क्या ऐसा ही होता
थोड़ा टाइम टेकिंग लगता है तो उसे पहले
वाले हम शब्द को ढूंढकर
बी ए टी ओ आर
कुछ तो मिलने वाला है
आवाज हमें गाड़ियां लगा सकते की हमारे पास
यह कुछ हो
16 17
चोर इमेज इमेज देखो यह इमेज एक और इमेज है
की जगह वहीं पर है और थोड़ा सा मिक्सर हो
जाता है की क्या इसी टावर के अंदर टावर
उनके अंदर लगा हुआ है बट वो इन वीडियो
साइज में फाइंड आउट करने की आईटी बिल टेक
टाइम तो ये लोग ये कम आप लोगों का है वो
क्या करना है की युटुब से किसी और चीज और
कंफर्म करना हो की यही टावर वन है और इसी
के अंदर वो क्या है
जी चीज का पता करने कुछ करो इसी के अंदर
है ओके आप लोग ये करोगे
हमारे पास सब कुछ ए गया हमारे पास
ओके वन मोर सिंह ओके
हो जाएगा
चलो फिर एक कम करते हैं एक टॉस हमने खत्म
कर दिया अपना एक टास्क हमने खत्म कर दिया
साड़ी चीज हम बैंड कर देते हैं फटाफट तो
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टास्कुर आने वाला आपके
सामने चलो तो इस तरीके से हम क्या है एक
और ओपन 100 सेंटर वेरी सक्सेसफुली तो अभी
बात करते हैं हम फिर से अपनी स्क्रीन पर ए
जाते हैं चलो तो अब नेक्स्ट आप लोगों के
लिए एक टास्क 2 है जिसमें आपको जो आपको
करके लेक आना है नेक्स्ट
तो नेक्स्ट क्या की ऑन जनवरी
192023 एक जनरलिस्ट विद ऑलमोस्ट 140 के
फॉलोअर्स ऑन ट्विटर
बड़े फूड ऑफ स्मोक और फायर
ब्रेकिंग टीटी सुसाइड अटैक
सिटी ऑफ पाकिस्तान डेट किल्ड 3 पाकिस्तान
पुलिस ऑफिसर
दी फोटो इस नोट डी इवेंट ऑफ डी स्टैंड बाय
डी जंगली सो वेरीफाई डी स्टेटमेंट अबोव जो
स्टेटमेंट मैं आपको जो बोल रही है की 19
जनवरी 2013 को एक ट्विटर से एक पोस्ट लिक
हुई है एक फोटो लिक हुई है उसके आधार पर
आपको एनालिसिस करना है क्या ये वो सही है
या गलत है आपको इस चीज को क्या करना है
एनालिसिस करना है इसको क्या करना है तो
इसके बाद में हम चलते हैं ये वो फोटो है
आपको जल्दी आपको मिल जाएगी मैं आपको बता
दूंगा कहां पर कौन सा नंबर पे है तो इस
फोटो को आपको मैसेज करना है तो वो आपका कम
है तो हम क्या करेंगे अपने थर्ड टास्क पर
चलते हैं चलें थर्ड पे
चले तो ये हमारा थर्ड है एक और एग्जांपल
है हमारा एग्जांपल थर्ड होना चाहिए
एग्जांपल तू लिख दिया मैंने इट्स ओके
जस्ट अभी सबसे बड़ा चैलेंज हमारे पास यहां
पर ये है ये हमारे पास जस्ट एक सिंपल फोटो
है और हमें क्या करना है की
ये जो कर डेंटल मां है इस फोटो के अंदर वन
तू थ्री फोर जो आपको दिखाई दे रहे हैं
की ये कौन है
वेरी टिपिकल टास्क आसन नहीं है यह अब देखो
की कर जेंटलमैन है एक हमारे पास फोटो है
फोटो भी बस सिर्फ इन्हीं के ऊपर फॉक्स
करके इसको उतारा गया है और उसके बेस पर
हमने क्या करना है इस चीज करना है और क्या
करना है आपको इन चारों के नाम आपको फाइंड
आउट करने हैं तो चलो फिर हम करते हैं
प्रैक्टिकल ओके
बैक्टीरिया तो मैं आपको बताता हूं की वो
टास्क कहां पर जो आपको करना है नेक्स्ट
चलो फिर हम चलते हैं सोफिया
जी पर चलते हैं ओके ये मेरे पास ऑलरेडी
मैंने ओपन कर रखा है पहले से ही ये वाला
हो गया हमारा टास्क जो आपको करना है टास्क
वो इस पे जाना है आपका टास्क है यह वाला
ऑप्शन एक्सिस
000x.com लिस्ट एक्सरसाइज
ओके तो अब बात करते हैं
इन फोटोस के आधार पर हमें पूरा एनालिसिस
करना है और पता करना है की जो यह कर
जैंटलमेंस है इनका नाम क्या है अब देखिए
इस फोटो को पहले एनसीसी स्टार्ट करते हैं
की आपको इस फोटो से क्या-क्या देखने को
मिल रहा है इस फोटो के आधार पर हम
क्या-क्या इनफॉरमेशन आपको देख सकते हैं ये
जूम भी नहीं होगा तो हम देखो सबसे पहले
बात आपको इस फोटो में क्या दिखाई दे रहा
है इस फोटो में आपको
जेंटलमैन कर लोग आपको दिखाई दे रहे हैं
1234 ओके और उसके बाद क्या है की हर चीज
को ध्यान से देखो देखो इमेज एनालिसिस की
यही खासियत वही हर चीज को ध्यान से देखो
यहां पर क्या दिखाई दे रहा आपको
मतलब ओके ताई लगे हुई है
स्क्रीन कलर
ब्लू कलर की और डॉटेड लाइन वाली क्या-क्या
टाइल लगा राखी है उसके बाद एक और जेंटलमैन
है जो इनके पीछे हैं जो क्लेम दिखाई दे
रहे हैं उन्होंने क्या है अपने फेस पर
चश्मा लगा रखा है ओके उसके बाद और क्या
देख सकते हो की जो है जेंटलमैन है जो
जिन्होंने क्या किया हाथ में पेन पड़ा हुआ
ओके अब पेन से हमने कंफर्म हो जाता है की
एक राइट हैंडेड है एक और इनफॉरमेशन कंफर्म
होगी दूसरा आपको एक लंबी सी टेबल दिखाई दे
रही है एक लंबी सी आपको टेबल दिखाई दे रही
है और टेबल के ऊपर आपको क्या दिखाई दे रहा
है हेडफोंस दिखाई दे रहे हैं अब जनरली एक
चीज होती है हेडफोन किसी भी जगह पर आपको
कहां देखने को मिलते हैं हेडफोंस हमें
वहां पर देखने को मिलते हैं जहां पर खासकर
ट्रांसलेशन का कम
ट्रांसलेशन का कम हो ऐसे कोई म्यूजिक के
लिए तो हेडफोन देता नहीं तो इसका मतलब
क्या है की यह ऐसी जगह है यहां पर जहां पर
ये बैठे हुए हैं अपने कर जेंटलमैन
बैठे हुए हैं
आपको जो दिखाई दे रहे हैं मतलब क्या यह एक
ऐसी जगह है यहां पर क्या है की हो सकता है
की यह कंट्री की मीटिंग हो तो कंट्री की
कॉन्फ्रेंस हो क्योंकि यहां पर ट्रांसलेटर
उसे मतलब यहां पर एक भाषा उसे नहीं होगी
मल्टीप्लेक्स भाषा का उसे किया था ऐसी जगह
अक्सर कौन सी होती है जहां पर
मल्टीप्लेक्स कंट्री का इंवॉल्व है ओके ये
कंफर्म क्लियर है उसके बाद बोतल देखिए
बोतल भी कोई सिंपल सी बोतल नहीं है वाटर
बोतल दे आर वेरी मतलब भी महंगी और कुछ
स्टाइलिश दिखाई दे रही है मतलब डेफिनेटली
बैकग्राउंड में क्या है आपको क्या है बैनर
लगा हुआ है मतलब कुछ ना कुछ तो यहां पर
कोई डील हो रही है या कोई कुछ इवेंट हो
रहा है मतलब इस बहाने से जो होता है जहां
पर कुछ इवेंट्स हो गए होते हैं या कुछ
डीलिंग हो रही होती है तो वहां पर अब इसको
हम ज्यादा पढ़ नहीं का रहे हैं क्योंकि
बिल्कुल ब्लू है तो इसको भी एडिट
को जूम करोगे तो बिल्कुल गलत हो जाएगा ऐसे
हम कुछ भी नहीं पढ़ा रहे हैं सिंगल शब्द
इवेंट हो रहा है या कोई डील हो रही है ऊपर
से साइनिंग करोगे ऊपर से हेडफोन को देख के
टेबल को देखिए बैनर को देख के मतलब
डेफिनेटली अगर मीडिया कवरेज होगा
डेफिनेटली यहां पर
मीडिया कवरेज हो रहा होगा
उसको पढ़ के और उसको फटाफट इनफॉरमेशन के
हां अगर प्रोवाइड करने की कोशिश कर रहा है
तो डोंट ट्राई खुद से अगर एनालिसिस करोगे
तो आपके लिए बटर होगा एडरवाइज आपके लिए
बहुत प्रॉब्लम हो जाएगी आप नहीं कर पाओगे
तो इस इतनी इनफॉरमेशन पता कर पे यहां से
अब हम इसको क्या करते हैं गूगल रिवर्स
सर्च करते हैं हम इसका क्या करते हैं
रिवर्स सर्च करते हैं तो ओके राइट क्लिक
करते हैं हमारे पास एक्सटेंशन है और इसको
हम क्या करते हैं इमेज रिवर्स सर्च करते
हैं और जल्दी से इमेज हो जो हो जो यार
पता नहीं
हमें कम करते हैं इसको डाउनलोडिंग कर लेते
डाउनलोड करते हैं
इसको
ओके
हमेशा कोशिश करते हैं इसको सर्च करने
को मिल रहे हैं कोई आर्टिकल नहीं मिलता
है
ओके ओके हम क्या देख का रहे हैं कुछ
सोर्सेस सोर्सेस हमें सिलेक्टेड
ओके हम देख रहे हैं
कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग देखने को मिला था मैं
यहां पर
देख रहा है
एवं सिक्योरिटी काउंसिल
एनिमल्स
17 दिसंबर 2015 या हमारे पास कुछ
इनफॉरमेशन
इसको बैंड कर देता हूं हमारे पास
अब हमारे पास क्या-क्या इनफॉरमेशन हमारे
पास
पॉलीटिकल एग्रीमेंट है उसके बाद कहां पर
है
और एक और कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीज
इसको ओपन करते हैं हम
अध्यक्ष झांसी देखो यह वेबसाइट इनकी है
ऊपर से क्या की इसके आधार पर हमें क्या
मिला है की यहां पर यह फोटो कब ली गई है
इन्हीं के दवा ली गई है तो इसका मतलब ये
फोटो इसके अंदर मिलने के चांसेस है ये
फोटो इसके अंदर मिलने के चांसेस हैं
ये फोटो इनके
राखी क्या बात है इतना फास्ट कम करते हो
क्या
इतना फास्ट कम करते हो क्या एनालिसिस खुद
से किया आर्टिकल के बेस पर क्या तुम कितना
एनालिसिस कर पे अगर वो आर्टिकल नहीं मिला
तो
तो हमें कम करते हैं इस इनफॉरमेशन के आधार
पर हम क्या करते हैं इसमें सर्च करते हैं
हमारे पास है हमारे पास क्या है
एस के
सीकृत और दिसंबर 17 है बा ओके सर्च करते
हैं इनफॉरमेशन ओके इससे रिलेटेड हमारे पास
कुछ इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल रही है
की 18 दिसंबर 15 17 दिसंबर
एग्रीमेंट हुआ तो ऊपर से क्या लिबींस
पार्टी साइन डी लेवल पॉलीटिकल ओके हम इसको
ओपन करते हैं नेक्स्ट ओपन न्यू टैब
नेक्स्ट हम इसको ओपन
पॉलीटिकल डायलॉग हैव टर्न डी पेज इन डी
हिस्ट्री
उसके बाद क्या है ओके चलो चलते हैं अब
यहां पर क्या है की इसको थोड़ा
मैच करने की कोशिश करेंगे ठीक है हम देखो
यहां पर कुछ इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल रही
है नो क्या सबसे पहले भारत स्टार्ट करते
हैं क्या आपको ग रहा है की ये सभी तीन
इनमें से कोई आपको आईडेंटिफाई कर का रहे
हो को ग रहा है की कोई भी एक जनरल मां से
मैच कर रहा होगा नो यह देखिए
इसके बाद स्पेस हैं बट इनके तरह नहीं है
सर पर बाल है इनके
नेक्स्ट इमेज को वेरीफाई करने को ये तीनों
वही लोग हैं तीनों डेंटल में नेक्स्ट हम
ट्राई करने को क्या इन तीनों इमेज में कोई
दिखाई दे रहा आपको इनमें से मैच कर रहा है
नो उसके बाद क्या हमें ग रहा है
उसके बाद नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट नो
कुछ खास पता लगाने वाले ओके नेक्स्ट
नेक्स्ट ओके
इमेज
हमारे पास मिली है तो इसको हम क्या करते
हैं इमेज को ओपन युटुब करते हैं इमेज को
हम एक तब ओपन करते हैं ये इमेज आपको
क्या कुछ मैच हो रहा है देखो अभी ये इनको
देखो और इनको देखो
थोड़ा-थोड़ा कुछ मैसेज देखो
थोड़ा ब्लैक है ओके स्टार्ट करते हैं
उसके बाद
इमेज में दिखाई दे रहा है
ओके तो अभी हम क्या कोड नंबर पर हैं हम
ट्राई कर रहे हैं आप आईडेंटिफाई करने ओके
उन्होंने क्या है एक गॉगल्स पहने हुआ है
ओके गूगल से स्टाइल का है बिल्कुल और हेयर
स्टाइल देखिए तो बिल्कुल आगे आईटी इसे जब
हाइट है और बिल्कुल लाइक डेट थोड़ा सा अगर
हम गैस करने को करते हैं देखो अगर हम इनको
थोड़ा जूम करने की देख कोशिश करें देखो
थोड़ा सा जो
कट ऑफ मार्क देखेंगे अगर बॉडी मास
आईडेंटिफाई करने की कोशिश करेंगे तो ऐसे
ही इनके चश्मा के ऊपर तो ये थोड़ा सा
एडिटिंग दिखेगा आपको अगर आप जूम कर पाते
देखो बिल्कुल एक आईटी इस आप देख का रहे
हैं उसके बाद क्या थोड़ा सा अगर यहां से
थोड़ा सा देखोगे ध्यान से इनके क्या स्पीड
है गाड़ी मतलब हम थोड़ा सा मिक्सर होगा की
ये जो फोर्थ हैं ये यही है जो हमारे पास
एक इमेज है हमारे पास ये वाली हमारे पास
एक इमेज है ये वाली एक पिक्चर है इस फोटो
कंपेयर करके
हमारे पास है
ओके बिल्कुल मिल गई हमें इमेज
नेक्स्ट देखिए
देखो यहां पर देखिए बिल्कुल
अरे कहां जा रहे हो
तो चलो ठीक है और कोई इनफॉरमेशन
यह जो पिक्चर आपको अगर दिखाई दे रही होगी
क्या जो हमें अभी एक पिक्चर ओपन की थी
इनकी बिल्कुल देखो
यही स्टाइल
जो इन्होंने को पहने हुआ है तो लाइक डेट
लाइनिंग के साथ टाइगर कलर अगर आईडेंटिफाई
करने कुछ करो तो लाइक डेट व्हाइट कलर
नेक्स्ट उसके बाद अगर यहां अगर हम देखते
हैं तो वही से से हमारे पास क्या है
क्लियर फोटो है एक ऐसे इंसान जिनकी हमारे
पास क्या है एक क्लियर फोटो है तो मतलब
बेसिकली करके हम क्या की दो लोगों की
इनफॉरमेशन कर पे बट अभी तक क्या है
क्योंकि तीन फोटोस हमारे पास है क्लियर बट
क्या की नाम हमें आईडेंटिफाई करने हैं
बट उनके पास हमारे पास इमेज है तो इसमें
और भी कोई इनफॉरमेशन है
[संगीत]
इसमें कोई देख नो नो मतलब अब इसके अलावा
किसी इनफॉरमेशन चाहिए
फर्स्ट टाइम कोई ऐसी मीटिंग है की कोई
फर्स्ट टाइम तो यह मीटिंग हो नहीं रही
होगी तो हो सकता की इससे पहले भी हुई हूं
क्योंकि कोई बिग डील होती है तो एक दिन
में तो होती नहीं तो चलो हम और कोशिश करते
इसमें पता करने की चलो इमेज और फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करते हैं की इमेज हमारे पास
से ही है नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट प्रोसेस
करते हैं
ओके ओके ओके हमें कुछ कुछ कुछ कुछ ओके हम
एक नाम
पॉलीटिकल डायलॉग
इनफॉरमेशन हो सकता है देखो एक तो यह
क्योंकि इससे रिलेटेड
उसके बाद नेक्स्ट कुछ और है ओनर बाय कोटा
लेवल पॉलीटिकल
ओके ओके एनीथिंग एल्स गेटिंग समथिंग
इनफॉरमेशन
करते हैं क्या इसके अंदर
पॉलीटिकल एग्रीमेंट इन डी सीक्रेट
[संगीत]
चलो कोशिश करते हैं
कुछ करते हैं
की अगर आप लोग देखोगे अगर मैं दिखाओ
इंटरेस्टिंग इनफॉरमेशन अगर यहां देखोगे
अगर आप चलो चलो चलो एक मिनट बैक करते हैं
उसके बाद एक ही देखो अगर हम इसको जूम करके
दिखाऊं आपको क्या दिखाई दे रहा है देखो
मैच नहीं कर रहे कुछ ग नहीं रहा आप लोगों
का ही वही होंगे जो हमने देखो यहां पर
देखें
ओके फाइल वही है और अगर हम कोशिश करें एक
और डेंटल मां की बात करते हैं अगर तो अगर
कोर्ट और ये इमेज देखना और ये इमेज
देखना और ये इमेज देखना देखो
थोड़ा-थोड़ा अगर ये शॉप की बात करें तो
क्या है थोड़ा-थोड़ा मैचिंग शॉप नहीं है
थोड़ा थोड़ा अगर आप लोगों को लगता है
थोड़ा मैच नहीं ग रहा वो बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
वही से ब्लू थोड़ा व्हाइट पेंट को अगर
थोड़ा सा देखिए इसमें दिए हैं इसके अलावा
और क्लेरिटी इमेज हमारे पास है नहीं बट
क्या इसी के आधार पर अगर हम यहां देखते
हैं तो थोड़ा वैसे मैच नहीं हो रहा ओके
उसके बाद वो देखते हैं चलो
यह हमारे पास अगर हम लगा सकते हैं की पता
लगा सकते हैं की ये वही है या नहीं है तो
मतलब थोड़ा सा आइडिया है ओके देखो
यह इनफॉरमेशन है क्योंकि ये हमारे पास
इमेज यहां पर क्लियर हो गई थी यहां पर ये
इमेज हमारे पास क्लियर हो गई थी इस इमेज
के अंदर ओके
अगर थोड़ा सा गूगल लेंस उसे कर पाएंगे
ओके ओके यूजिंग गूगल इमेज मैग्नीफायर
नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो
नो नो नो नो नो नो नो नो अगर रब भी आइडिया
लगा पाते हैं डॉक्यूमेंट
टेबल
कर रहा है इतना हार्ड तो इनका यहां तक और
कर रहा है
ओके तो हम हो सकता है
तो अगर हम देखते हैं थोड़ा सा और कोशिश
करते हैं
फाइल का और ग रहा है
क्योंकि क्योंकि
यह बिल्कुल
लास्ट में यहां पर फाइल खत्म होने वाली ही
है अगर हम गैस लगाते हैं तो एक कम करते
हैं हम पहले की हमारे पास क्या नाम है इधर
से इसको हम क्या करते हैं
इमेज रिवर्स सर्च करते हैं गूगल इमेज
रिवर्स सर्च कर देते हैं इसको
मोबाइल हो गया क्या
मेरा गूगल इमेज सर्च अलग तरीके से ही कम
करता है पता नहीं
मैं इसको एक कम कर देता हूं इसको डाउनलोड
ही करता हूं मैं इसको क्या करता हूं थोड़ा
डाउनलोड
चलो करो भैया
ट्रांसलेट करने की बात करते हैं ओके नो
यहां पर कुछ देखने को मिल रहा होगा आपको
नहीं तो अगर हम यहां का टेस्ट के बाद करते
हैं तो देखो
अबोगेश्वर ओके अगर हम इसको अगर ज्यादा अगर
ट्रांसलेट भी करते हैं तो हम ट्रांसलेट कर
सकते हैं ओके अगर हम करते क्योंकि यह वही
इमेज से इमेज है देखो ये से इमेज है
विकिपीडिया में पढ़ोगे इनके बड़े में
पढ़ोगे इसको हम ट्रांसलेट भी कर सकते हैं
पूरे पेज को कैसे करेंगे तो हम कर सकते
हैं सिंपली हमारे पास ट्रांसलेटर है
ट्रांसलेट दिस पेज नेक्स्ट ओके
मुस्तफा आबू शाखा हमारे पास मतलब एक हमारे
पास नाम ए गया हमारे पास क्या एक नाम है
मुस्तफा देखो उसके बाद हूं इसे डी मोस्ट
इसके बड़े में आप जा सकते हो की न्यूलीबिन
प्राइम मिनिस्टर हैं अभी ये और इनके बड़े
में कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
दे सकते हो मीटिंग में देख सकते हो और भी
देख सकते हो मतलब क्या की हमारे पास एक
नाम है मुस्तफा
मतलब एक हमारे पास नाम ए गया उसके बाद चलो
ठीक है एक हम कंफर्म कर पे तो एक व्यक्ति
का हमारे पास नाम है इनका हमारे पास मिल
गया
स्टार्टिंग में बात की थी एक मिनट अगर कोई
इमेज अच्छी थी मैंने यहां पर ये नहीं थी
इसका हमारा कम हो गया अभी इसको मैं रिमूव
कर देता हूं इसको डाउनलोड कर लिया मैंने
यह देखिए यह इमेज
के बड़े में क्या इनफॉरमेशन गूगल पता लगा
पता है
ट्रांसलेट करने की बट अगर हुआ तो कर पाएगा
अदर वाइस नहीं कर पाएगा अगर हम सेक्स
देखते हैं
मां मोहम्मद
इसको मैं पूरा हाईलाइट करता हूं क्या यह
और कुछ इनफॉरमेशन ए रही है और यह कुछ
इनफॉरमेशन ए रही है ओके चलो कोई बात नहीं
कम करते हैं हमारे पास इमेज है ना तो हम
एक कम करते हैं चलो ओके दिस इनफॉरमेशन
थोड़ा जूम कर लेते हैं अब ये साइन कहां पर
है देखो साइन कहां पर कर रहे हैं अगर
ध्यान से देखोगे फर्स्ट सेकंड थर्ड नंबर
पर साइन करने हैं क्योंकि हमारे पास तो
साइन की पिक्चर्स है चलो बेस्ट हमारे लिए
इससे बेस्ट कोई चीज होगी क्या हम बैक करते
हैं वापस से अपने पिक्चर में जाते हैं
थर्ड नंबर हमारे पास ये थर्ड नंबर ये
हमारे पास है तो इसको कॉपी करते हैं और
पता करने की कोशिश करते हैं की कोई भी
परसों तो हम गूगल जाते हैं नेक्स्ट उनके
नाम पता करते हैं हमारे पास ये
करते हैं
की ये वही पसंद है
तो यहां पर हमारे पास
करो करो ना ट्रांसलेट करो
इनकी इमेज
अभी इस नाम को आईडेंटिफाई करने का सही
करते हैं की नाम है क्या इसको ट्रांसलेट
करते हैं हम इसको इंग्लिश
ओके चलो हम इसको एक कम करते थे इंग्लिश
में ट्रांसलेट तो कर लिया तो हमें जो नाम
देखने को मिल रहा है इंग्लिश में भी अगर
हम सर्च करके देखेंगे
[संगीत]
हद होती है
इसको कॉपी करो यार कॉपी
पप्पी कुछ करते हैं
ओके चलो चलो चलो
अरे यह कुछ दिखा रहा है गूगल भी पागल हो
गया
इनफॉरमेशन रिलेटेड
इमेज
इनके बड़े में काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन निकाल
गई है तो मतलब दो नाम हमारे सामने ए गए
कंफर्म करोगे थोड़ा सा और गूगल सर्च करना
पड़ेगा तो टाइम मिलेगा तो अभी देखो एक चीज
बताइए
तो एक चीज बताइए की आप सब लोग 7:30 हो गए
हैं
की क्या सबको अच्छा ग रहा है
देखो इस तरीके से किसी भी
इंसान की इनफॉरमेशन निकाल जा शक्ति है
उनके भी सिग्नेचर के अंदर है वो हमें
आईडेंटिफाई करने हैं उनके बेसिक पे हम
एनालिसिस करना और उनके नाम हम क्या कर
सकते हैं निकाल सकते हैं उनकी इनफॉरमेशन
निकाल सकते हैं तो इस तरीके से हमने दो
जेंटलमैन का नाम है हमने फाइंड आउट कर
लिया है
और दो का बच्चा है तो ये आप लोग कर लोग
इन दो का आप लोग कर सकते हैं
बताइए क्या था थोड़ा सा बोर्ड ग रहा है
आकाश हो जा
थोड़ा सा
कोई जादू
की अब किसी एक्सिस के लिए मैं तुमसे पहले
से थोड़ा सा करके आता हूं प्रिपरेशन
क्योंकि अदर वाइस अगर तुम्हारे इतना मैं
बैठे-बैठेगा|
पता करने में कितना टाइम लगेगा तो एक कम
कीजिए
यह जो बैक गया इस इमेज के जो जो किशन नंबर
कौन सा था सोफिया का मारा यह इस इमेज के
मैंने इनका नाम पता कर लिया और इनका नाम
पता कर दिया बाकी जो बैक गए इन दो का दो
का नाम आपको पता करना है और कमेंट में
कमेंट करके बताओगे सभी के सभी की इन दो
शख्स का नाम क्या है ओके एक्सरसाइज नंबर
सिक्स है एक्सल नंबर कौन सी थी वो अगर हम
बैक करते हैं तो ये एक्सरसाइज नंबर आपकी
अगर जाओगे तो यह आपको देखना मिलेगा बस
सॉल्यूशन मत देखना कोई भी ऑप्शन नंबर 11
नंबर
बोला था की फाइंड करना करें
ऑलरेडी काफी लॉन्ग सेशन हो गया हमारा काफी
बड़ा सेशन
का नाम पता करना आपका कम है तो हो जाएगा
है अगर उसके घर पर क्लिक किया है और हमें
उसका स्क्रीनशॉट लेकर सेंड किया तो उसका
लोकेशन हम हमें मिल सकता है क्या देखो
क्या होता है
की ट्राई हो सकता है
आप एक कम करो किसी रूम के अंदर फोटो लेकर
उसको आपने मोबाइल में से करके रखा हुआ है
तो उसके लिए इस टाइप अलग है पॉसिबल सब कुछ
है
अगर पब्लिकली अवेलेबल तो
तो एक कम करते हैं फिर काफी स्ट्रैंथ है
लेकिन तो देखो प्रेजेंट स्टेटस आप लोग मिल
रहा है और कमेंट आउट करके वहां पर भी
बताइए आप लिंकडइन
परफॉर्मेंस के लिए और आज का जो टास्क पीछे
क्लास का तास और आज का तास और साथ में एक
थर्ड टास्क किया इंवॉल्व हो गया की दो नाम
मैंने पता कर दिए दो नाम आप लोगों को पता
करने हैं वो आपको क्या करना है कमेंट करके
बताने हैं कहां पर लिंकडइन पेज पर की ये
दो नाम कौन से हैं देखिए एक चीज ध्यान
रखना की अगर कोई भी हो सकता है कोई लाइव
क्लास में नहीं आया तो यह लिंकडइन पेज पर
कमेंट करके कोई भी बता सकता है चाहे कोई
इस वीडियो को 1 साल बाद देख रहा है दो साल
बाद देख रहा है तो वह सेंड करके इसकी
इनफॉरमेशन क्या कर सकता हमें दे सकता है
लेकिन पेज पर
डेफिनेटली वे बिल उसके लिए हम क्या करेंगे
उसके लिए पक्का करेंगे इस चीज की चिंता
करने की जरूर करते हैं तो कल सेशन नहीं
होगा क्योंकि मुझे भी टाइम चाहिए
काफी मजा आएगा आपको अभी क्या की काफी कुछ
बता दिया मैंने एक लैब करेंगे वो सेंड के
ऊपर काफी इंटरेस्टिंग लैब है
जहां से मैंने लिया है उसमें आपको
बता दूंगा वो आपके लिए भी रहेगी परफॉर्म
करने के लिए और
काफी इंटरेस्ट आपको मजा आएगा
कैसे
मतलब काफी मजेदार
ओके तो अगर आप लोगों को ग रहा है
यह बताइए
ओके नेक्स्ट क्लास में आपको सब एक्सरसाइज
लेकर आऊंगा
एक्सरसाइज करेंगे उसमें और ट्राई करेंगे
की दो पॉसिबल एक्सरसाइज करेंगे
उसके बाद हम स्टार्ट करेंगे कुछ ट्विटर और
सेंड इंस्टाग्राम
रिलेटेड हैं वो हम स्टार्ट करेंगे आने
वाले सेशंस में ओके नो इट्स तू
क्लास होगी इमेज
मिलेंगे उसके बाद जो हम डिलीवर करने वाले
हैं नेक्स्ट एक क्लास के बाद और हम
डिलीवरी करेंगे फिर इंस्टाग्राम
करते हैं